Justice.
Oliver Wendell Holmes once famously said that the duty to keep a contract at
common law means a prediction that you must pay damages if you do not keep it
and nothing else.
Imagine you sign a contract stating that you will perform renovations at another
person's apartment in return for $500 payment upfront and $3,000 total homes is
quote suggests that you have not so much promise that you will do the
renovations,
but only that you promise to perform or pay damages if you do not do them.
The distinction may initially seem unclear or even only a matter of semantics,
but today we're going to discuss promissory fraud,
a doctrine that demonstrates just how important this distinction is.
And by the way,
I have a small obsession with promissory fraud and Greg class and I have written
an entire book called insincere promises.
And so if you want to learn more about it,
you can always,
uh,
look up that book.
So a claim of promissory fraud is simply a claim that when a promise or made a
promise,
the promise or did not intend to keep that promise.
If a party prove such a claim,
a court can impose punitive damages on the promissory note.
As a reminder,
punitive damages are damages awarded to punish a party's behavior and not to
compensate the breached party for the losses the that the breach causes.
The goal of punitive damages is to deter a the certain behavior.
The award of CUNYs are exceedingly rare in contractual cases,
but promissory fraud is one of the places where you might win them.
Taking up again our renovation contract example,
if you promise to do the renovations because you needed the $500 up front
payment but had no intention of actually performing the renovations,
you could end up paying not just expectation damages for the buyers value of the
contract,
but also damages punishing you specifically for misrepresenting your intent to
fulfill your promise.
Some people have trouble seeing promissory insincerity as even a kind of
misrepresentation.
But to paraphrase a famous English case,
a person's intention is as much a fact as what he or she had for breakfast that
morning and hence intention might be expressly or implicitly misrepresented.
Both.
The restatement of torts and the restatement of contracts contain provisions on
promissory fraud.
The Tort restatement provides that a representation of the makers own intention
to do or not do a particular thing is fraudulent if he does not have that
intention.
Comments see to this provision explains its application to misrepresentation of
intent to perform an agreement quote.
Since a promise necessarily carries with it the implied assertion of an
intention to perform it,
it follows that a promise made without such an intention is fraudulent and
actionable.
The restatement of contracts uses language that initially seems not quite as
decisive.
Section one 71 subparagraph two provides that if it is reasonable to do so,
the promise,
he may properly interpret a promise as an assertion that the promise or intends
to perform the promise but comment be brings the provision closer to the
categorical torch provision.
Clarifying quote,
it is ordinarily reasonable for the prophecy to infer from the making of a
promise that the promise or intends to perform it if therefore the promise is
made with the intention of not performing it.
This implied assertion is false and a misrepresentation.
Unsurprisingly,
the primary difficulty in any promissory fraud case is proving the promissory
his intent.
At the time the promise was made.
Both the restatement of torts and contracts make clear that the mere fact of
nonperformance is not itself sufficient to prove the promise or never intended
to perform his promise to breaching promised or might've s simply changed her
mind.
That is changed her intent after promising
that tort restatement ads as well,
that the promises nonperformance doesn't place on the promise or the burden of
showing that he failed to carry out his promise for reasons that didn't arise
until after the parties entered into an agreement.
It's the promise.
See that retains the burden in a promissory fraud claim of actually proving that
the promise or did not intend to perform.
So what kinds of evidence might a party use to show that the promissor
misrepresented his or her intent and never intended to actually perform her
promise?
A pattern of repeated breaching promises over and over again over time can be
powerful,
circumstantial evidence that a promise or never intended to carry out his
promises.
Think of the musical,
the music man,
uh,
the plot centers on a so-called professor Harold Hill,
who pretends in community after community to be a band I organizer and
repeatedly sells town members,
band instruments and uniforms by promising that he will teach their children to
be musicians and then he skips town.
The fact that hill makes the same promise over and over and never performs
compellingly suggests that he never intended to fulfill his promises at the time
of promising.
In fact,
under Illinois law,
plaintiffs must prove such a pattern called a scheme to defraud in order to
prove a promissory fraud claim.
As judge Richard Posner has explained by requiring that the plaintiff show a
pattern by this not letting him rest on proving a single false promise,
promise the law reduces the likelihood of a spurious suit.
For a series of unfulfilled promises is better though,
of course not conclusive evidence of fraud then a single unfulfilled promise,
but evidence of such a scheme isn't necessary.
Another jurisdictions and factors beyond a pattern of false promises of,
of a series of breaches,
a can also be probative of promissory fraud.
Perhaps the most commonly raised type of evidence is lack of change
circumstance,
a promise or who fails to perform and who is accused of misrepresentation
usually will argue that he or she fully intended to carry out the promise when
making it but then events or circumstances subsequently arose which caused him
or her to change his or her mind.
Uh,
it's especially probative that there is a lack of change circumstances when the
time period between the making of a promise and the breaching of it is short
because this lack of time suggest that the promise or misrepresented his or her
intention.
If you rent a car promising to return it in a week and immediately after driving
it off the rental lot,
go sell it to someone else,
courts are likely to infer that you never intended to return it.
Courts will also consider whether it would have been possible for the promise or
to perform his or her promise at the time the promise was made.
Consider the music man example again,
assume Harold Hill did not know how to play a musical instrument.
He couldn't possibly have taught the children of those to whom he sold
instruments,
how to play those instruments.
This would be good evidence of promissory fraud because of the,
uh,
the promise or knew that at the time of promising that his performance would be
impossible.
Finally,
courts may look at internal documents from the promise or indicating that the
promise or had no intent to perform emails showing the promise or had plans to
be in a different location at the time or performance.
Uh,
uh,
for instance would fall into this category.
Finally,
it's important for us to recognize how promissory fraud law can be and has been
subject to misuse a labor law.
Uh,
in the Jim Crow South provides an egregiously clear example.
th this law which,
uh,
was on the books in Alabama in the first decade of the 20th century,
made it a crime for any employee,
uh,
with an intent to defraud his employer Tanner into an a,
a contract obtained money from the employer for the promised act or services and
then fail to perform the promise.
Further,
the statute made an employee's failure to perform prime aphasia evidence of the
employee's intent to defraud.
The statute was enforced almost exclusively against African Americans and the
statute was challenged in Bailey versus Alabama.
And in a 1911 opinion authored by Justice Charles Evans Hughes,
the Supreme Court found that it violated the 13th amendment,
ironically,
just as homes dissented arguing that quote,
a false representation expressed or implied at the time of making the contract
of Labor that one intends to perform it and thereby obtaining an advance may be
declared a case of fraud,
gently obtaining money as well as any other,
that if made a crime,
it may be punished like any other crime.
Holmes's scholarly theory that a contractual promise is nothing more than a duty
to perform or pay damages might suggest a limited ambit for promissory fraud
because the promissor might argue that her promise merely implied that she
intended to perform or pay damages.
But Justice Holmes had what many believe to be one of his weakest descents,
was willing to countenance Alabama's attempt to use promissory fraud to shore up
a system of Jim Crow,
labor restrictions targeting African Americans.
So what have we learned?
We've learned that usually when you make a promise,
you imply have asserted an intention to perform that promise.
As a result,
when a party can prove that you never actually intended to carry out what you
promised,
that party may recover punitive damages,
not just whatever amount that party's entitled to by virtue of your contractual
breach,
but an amount that punishes you for the misrepresentation and attempts to deter
you from making such misrepresentations in the future.
We also talked about what kinds of evidence might serve to prove that you had no
intention of keeping your promise,
a pattern,
or a scheme to defraud,
the lack of change circumstances,
impossibilities of performance,
or ancillary private documents.
Finally,
we discussed Bailey versus Alabama,
uh,
in which a statute improperly presumed promissory fraud from any employees
breach,
at least when the employee was African American.